épicentre du double séisme de lundi
dernier c'est ici à Caraman des
quartiers complets se sont écroulés
comme des châteaux de cartes
il fait de plus en plus froid mais les
efforts pour retrouver des survivants se
poursuivent sans beaucoup d'aide des
autorités locales nous souffrent les
habitants
si c'est le voisinage qui a payé pour
une pelle mécanique
ailleurs les secours de l'État
commencent à se mettre en place mais ils
sont peu et il manque de tout dit style
loin des caméras
le temps est un ennemi impitoyable c'est
surtout le bilan accablant des morts qui
continuent de s'agourdir
c'est pour faire taire ceux qui
reprochent au gouvernement sa lenteur à
réagir que Twitter a été bloqué par les
principaux fournisseurs d'Internet en
Turquie aujourd'hui les familles ils
partagaient leurs doléances et leur
colère
et c'est aussi peut-être ce qui explique
la visite du président erdan Marrakech
aujourd'hui
nous avons eu des problèmes à certains
endroits dans la première étape nous
avons eu des problèmes sur les routes
mais nous gérons mieux aujourd'hui et
nous gèrerons mieux encore demain
c'est-il défendu c'est secouriste
étranger aussi commence à arriver à
carnaval c'est avec eux beaucoup plus de
moyens sophistiqués pour poursuivre les
recherches
ceux-là sont arrivés hier de Russie et
travail depuis la nuit dernière équipé
de drones de caméra thermique et de
chien pisteurs ils aident à retrouver
des survivants pour concentrer les
efforts des sauveteurs
ici on assure qu'une femme est resté
coincée sous les décombres sa mère ne
tient plus les équipes turques n'ont
rien pu faire
ils sont venus repartis ils ont dit
qu'il n'y avait rien je ne tiens plus
c'est insupportable dit-elle
une première inspection à l'aide des
caméras ne permet pas de retrouver sa
fille tengrill la chienne de l'équipe
entre en scène son verdict est sans
appel dit André son maître
cherche les vivants mais ici et
survivants il dit qu'il n'y en a aucun
sans signe de vie les équipes irroyeurs
les morts doivent attendre
à Gaziantep mais sa famille attendent
aussi ils ont perdu leur maison et
dorment sur ce banc depuis lundi soir
nous avons besoin de temps et d'aide
maintenant dit-il nous sommes dans une
situation vulnérable
sur cette place publique sont loin de
suffire à accueillir tous ceux qui sont
déplacés
Mohamed n'ose plus aller chez lui alors
il passe ses nuits ici avec ses quatre
enfants comme 3600 000 Syriens ils ont
fui la guerre dans leur pays en Turquie
on y va pour prendre des choses mais à
chaque fois qu'il y a des tremblements
on vient se réfugier sous le pont à
cause du froid tous les enfants sont
malades ils obtiendront peut-être une
tente avec de la chance dis-moi Ahmed
résigné mais c'est la misère qui le
poursuit
c'est aussi la misère qui s'exprime ici
dans le chaos d'une distribution d'aide
qui réduit cette femme aux larmes entre
le lancer des vêtements des bouteilles
d'eau et des couches pour bébé elle
n'arrive pas à tirer son épingle du jeu
et c'est aussi cette même misère qui met
cette femme en colère turc elle se
demande pourquoi tous ces syriens devant
elle reçoit de l'aide alors qu'à elle il
ne reste plus rien sauf le sentiment que
beaucoup partagent ici d'être oublié
ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada quasiante